hey youtubers it's Charlie so there's a
whole bunch of course stuff happening
right now they just posted a new trailer
episodes are gonna start airing next
week and they're streaming everything
from books 1 & 2 on Nick's website right
now I also wanted to announce that I'm
gonna be doing a weekly Korra giveaway
during the season so be sure to
subscribe to get everything I'll explain
how it's gonna work at the end of this
video right now to the important stuff
book 3 premiere date Nick is dropping
those first three episodes Friday June
27th at 4 p.m. Eastern Time
normally episodes will air at 5 p.m.
Eastern Time so just adjust based on
which time zone you live in the first
two episodes are called a breath of
fresh air as an airbenders and rebirth
of a nation as in rebirth of the air
nation that second episode is gonna
explain why there are so many new
airbenders popping up everywhere hint
hint
harmonic convergence episode 3 is gonna
air right after that so it's basically
three new episodes at once the third
episode is called the earth Queen she's
the daughter of the earth King from Last
Airbender and her name is hooting as in
who is the new earth Queen she's not
super nice and was heavily featured in
those leaked episodes so please be
careful if you want to talk about her in
the comments just use spoiler tags if
you did see those episodes here's some
weirdness though as awesome as getting
all three episodes at once is there will
be no new episode the week after that so
they're doing three episodes next week
then no episode fourth of July weekend
it's an American holiday for any
international people saying WTF and then
Episode four is gonna air July 11th so
second big order of business Nick is
streaming all the episodes from book 1 &
2 on their website Nick comm so you can
totally catch up if you skipped either
one of those but it's a good opportunity
to jump on if you want to learn about
Korra before book three if you've never
watched the series before it's some of
the best Western anime that you will
ever watch and it's gonna be really fun
this summer so be sure to check it out
there's only gonna be 13 episodes in
book three and they're each only a half
hour long so it's a very low time
commitment it's gonna be a Friday night
show but you can totally DVR it and make
it a Saturday morning cartoon show all
the videos that I'm gonna be making for
each episode will post a couple hours
after each episode airs so you can watch
those Friday nights but now here's a
breakdown to that new footage in the
second trailer that they just posted the
opening scene sets up the post harmonic
convergence world Tenzin is a bit
mysterious
but when he talks about change being
good or bad he's referring to the
effects harmonic convergence had on the
physical realm because both the spirit
portals were left open after harmonic
convergence and spirits are everywhere
the spiritual alignment of the world has
changed a lot they buried the lede a
little but the reason the avatar exists
is to serve as an intermediary between
the spirit world in the physical realm
but what do you do if there's no more
barrier between those places do you even
need an avatar anymore that's gonna be
one of the big stories of book 3
what is Korra's role in this new super
balanced world all these spirit vines
you see her coming with the waterbending
technique the dark avatar totter I'm
totally gonna call him that just because
it's way cooler than calling him unlock
there's gonna be like the homes for the
spirits like the places where they start
to proliferate the reason chorus trying
to calm them is because their spirit
vines they seed with spiritual energy so
whenever things get too crazy near then
they start to go crazy so it looks like
core is going to be patrolling Republic
City a little bit trying to help people
learn about how their emotions can
affect the spirits the Republic City in
the world in general that we saw in
books wanted to is heavily modernized
you know mix and cars running around
everywhere so part of the dark avatars
mission in book 2 was to crush all that
and give rise to a new spiritual age
where the spirit world dominated the
physical realm so most people will have
no idea what's going on with the spirits
or how to deal with them so then we see
a bunch of the evil benders breaking out
of their prisons some better shots of
them the Airbender the earthbender the
waterbender and the firebender slash
sparky-sparky boom girl we haven't seen
her use that power in the trailers yet
or in the leaked episodes but don't be
surprised that she does it whenever she
breaks out of her prison Zuko narrates a
lot of the action just saying that
they're basically a group of prodigy
benders but they're really really bad
the firebender doesn't Bend blue flame
like Azula the most infamous prodigy
bender aside from the dark avatar but I
think it's safe to say that whenever
they're together as a team they can kick
team cores but so part of her journey in
book 3 will be finding a way to defeat
them that does not involve bending
here's some more shirtless Tenzin that
we saw in that league trailer not sure
why he's shirtless but I know some of
you guys thought that was really funny
the first time we saw it
these earth benders that Asami in korra
are battling are at the desert oasis
remember we saw a couple of other scenes
with maka
Bolin and Korra and Asami fleen plus
that evil earthbender heating up all
those rocks into lava either the Oasis
is where his prison was or something
else really really shady is going on
there then we get full-on confirmation
that Bumi is becoming an airbender I'm
so happy about this it was such a bummer
that he was born of the Avatar lineage
but did not have bending abilities Bumi
and Bolin are gonna be where most of the
comedy flows from this season which is
gonna be a really nice change of pace
for all you who are bummed out by all
the horrific deaths on Game of Thrones
that we just got done witnessing here's
the deal with all the airbenders in the
description of the first episode it
talks about airbenders popping up
randomly all over the world so episode 2
is going to feature Korra and Tenzin
traveling all over the world trying to
find them and bring them together
basically with the idea of rebuilding
the airbending nation they pretty much
been extinct since Aang's time you know
dot last airbender they talked about
this a little bit during book 2 and all
those Tenzin family scenes kya and Bumi
were a little bit resentful of Tenzin as
a child because he was the first new
Airbender in the world so Aang cook him
everywhere with him and now there's
hundreds of new airbenders post harmonic
convergence here's a couple more scenes
involving that Dai Li unless you've
watched those leaked episodes their
presence is a little mysterious but
they're up to something really really
evil so if you have seen those episodes
and want to talk about them please use
the spoiler tags in the comments just in
case people don't want to know here's a
shot of Korra in the Avatar State which
makes me a little relieved I saw a lot
of people speculating that she would be
unable to enter the Avatar State as a
result of what happened last year with
the dark avatar but I think it's safe to
say that she's just the first in a new
line of avatars I know a lot of you have
been wondering whether or not she's
going to be you know verbally
communicating with raava like avatar
wanted during book 2 I'm not expecting
it but if April Stewart shows up on the
credits sheet in the end credits then
we'll know and that's pretty much it for
new footage I'm glad that Nik is airing
the episodes early like everyone
expected them to there was this news
going around last week that said it was
airing in September on the Brazilian
affiliate station but they didn't say
anything about where it was airing
everywhere else so it was really
confusing I don't necessarily agree with
them airing episodes and clumps and then
doing no episodes and then doing one
episode it's a little bit disjointed but
I'll take what I can get so let me know
what your mo
excited to see this season here's the
details on my weekly giveaway so I'm
gonna be picking someone randomly from
the comments on my episode videos so
because there's three episodes next week
there's gonna be three different winners
all you have to do to participate is be
a subscriber and leave a comment on my
episode videos that also includes this
video I'm actually starting to give away
with this video so it's just my way of
saying thank you to subscribers for
being so awesome that's why it's only
open to subscribers what it is is an
Amazon gift card if you're in the US and
if you're international as just PayPal
so it's open to international people the
only rule is no I just pick the
winners randomly from the comments but
after I pick someone I do check all the
comments that they've ever left on my
channel in case they've been super mean
to other people or on any of the videos
so please remember to be nice to
everyone
it makes YouTube so much more fun when
people are nice since they're streaming
all of book 1 and 2 on nick.com my next
bonus video is just gonna be a breakdown
of all the important events that have
preceded book 3 that are going to be
affecting the plot in book 3 so be sure
to subscribe to get that feel free to
leave me any suggestions for future
bonus videos so I'm also still
collecting questions for my personal
acuity I'm gonna be doing that at VidCon
so feel free to ask me any personal
questions you want on this video and I
will answer them as long as they're not
super gross right now click here for my
book 3qa
and click here for my breakdown to the
first trailer thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys tonight
high fives